And finally, New Rule.
Democrats must learn how
to support
a very important part
of their coalition:
other Democrats.
(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
I know everyone is excited
about Conor Lamb
winning in Pennsylvania
this week
but watching his TV ad
is why I worry...
about how this party fights.
LAMB: My opponent wants you
to believe the biggest issue
in this campaign
is Nancy Pelosi.
It's all a big lie.
I've already said
on the front page
of the newspaper
that I don't support
Nancy Pelosi.
Okay, so this was
a special election
to replace a Republican
who was staunchly pro-life
but got caught
pressuring his mistress
to have an abortion...
and the Democrats let it
become a referendum
on Nancy Pelosi?
How about this for an ad?
"Democrats support abortion.
So do Republicans when they
need one for their girlfriend."
(APPLAUSE)
Nancy Pelosi... was never
a scary radical,
and Democrats, long ago,
made a horrible mistake
in deciding that,
when the Republicans
called her that,
they would just duck
their heads and go along.
-(SPARSE APPLAUSE)
-What Nancy Pelosi did...
was pass the stimulus
that averted a depression,
passed the very best version
of a healthcare bill
this country's ever had,
pass Wall Street reform
after the Great Recession,
and the bill that saved
the auto industry,
passed the Fair Pay Act...
These are things to brag about,
not distance yourself from.
(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
Learn the lesson
that's staring you in the face
every day in the person
of Donald Trump.
Voters don't care
about how smart you are,
just don't be a pussy.
(SPARSE APPLAUSE)
Hilary Clinton got 26 percent
of the vote
in West Virginia.
Trump did better
with Hispanics
after calling them
rapists and killers.
Trump once said,
to a crowd in Iowa...
How stupid are the people
of Iowa?
(SPARSE LAUGHTER)
...and then won Iowa
in a landslide...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
...as the people cried,
"It's about time
somebody levelled with us
about how stupid we are!"
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Their attitude is
"Insult me, lie to me,
just lead me."
Hilary had the right plan
for Coal Country:
get them off coal.
Now, we've got to move
away from coal,
and all the other
fossil fuels,
but I don't want to move
away from the people
who did the best they could
to produce the energy
that we relied on.
Yeah. Everything
about that answer was right.
But she did what Democrats
always do.
The second there was
the slightest backlash,
she back-pedaled.
It was a mis-statement,
because what I was saying is
that--
(RECORD SCRATCH)
Stop. Stop! You already lost.
It wasn't a mis-statement,
it was the truth.
(APPLAUSE)
(LAUGHS)
She should have said,
"You heard me.
Coal is dead
and it's about God-damned time.
It's dirty, it's killing
the environment,
and it's killing you,"
instead of pretending
it's a great thing
that a West Virginia man
can die in a hole
looking for rocks,
just like his daddy
-and his daddy before that.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
(LAUGHS)
How about, "We're the party
that's gonna get you
out of the hole"?
(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
What happened to selling
the American dream
of a better life for your kids?
But Democrats are
to political courage
what Velveeta is to cheese.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Republicans just added
80 billion
to a defense budget that was
already more than Russia's,
China's and the next five
countries' combli-- combined,
including Wakanda.
(LAUGHTER)
And the Democrats
went right along,
when they should be saying,
"This isn't defense spending,
it's welfare
for defense contractors..."
(APPLAUSE)
"...and the reason we never
have money for anything else."
But just like the Democrats'
position on coal -
"Love it! Had some
for breakfast!" -
and guns -
"I love the second amendment
too!" -
they're afraid to make
the counter-argument.
Republicans, they're all claws
and sharp teeth and fangs
when they fight.
The Democrats?
Their weapon of choice
is adaptive coloration.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
"I'm a leaf!"
"Don't eat me!"
(LAUGHTER)
"Vote for me, I'm the same
pattern as the couch!"
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
(SPARSE APPLAUSE)
(APPLAUSE GROWS)
So, how about this, Democrats?
Let's create a brand-new issue
out of thin air,
just like the Republicans do.
And you can use it
to practice having balls.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
And we'll pick an issue
that actually would help you.
And that issue is this:
Why the fuck do we need
two Dakotas?
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Are they really that different?
I don't think so.
Combined, these two states,
with a total population
of 1.6 million,
get four Senators.
California,
with a total population of...
"Have you seen the 405?"...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
...get two.
There are more people
in California named "Dakota"
than there are in the Dakotas.